oh my god i
i missed the idea
that is that is terrifying
what is going on there reject nation i'm
greg
you are slate your name please hi my
name is ashley edner
guys we're going to watch today from uh
one of the it's been a while since we've
been
you know what i'm trying to say
supernatural ghost videos he's already
spooked he can't even perform sentences
just based off this icon i'm so so
terrified about this are these real
ghosts caught on camera from slapped ham
we will be the judges of this we will
tell you what is real and what isn't but
guys
i wanted to cover some scary videos
again just for my own pleasure
and also i was like let's get ashley on
here because on june 20th
ashley is the series one of the series
regular
take two ashley is one of the series
regulars
of is that a word series regulars sure
one of the cast members series regular
of a show that is doing well it's season
two
of evil on paramount plus comes out june
20th
paramount plus that's exactly what i
said yes
and it's gonna be very spooky it's a
halloween edition
yeah yeah it's uh if you haven't seen
the trailer go ahead check that out
looks great looks scary
i've seen your character ashley's
playing illegally abby
and she is scary it is a wicked
that's i don't know what i'm allowed to
say and not to say what am i supposed to
say what am i not supposed to say is
your manager going to call me yell at me
you guys should just tune in to find out
what happens
but she's very scary yeah
all right let's do this guy
how you doing i'm calling and this is
slapped ham today we're looking at some
chilling video clips that really do need
explaining
so hit that subscribe button and get
ready for more creepy content
just like this let's see slap him
every once in a while a piece of
security camera footage of alleged
ghosts caught on camera
appears online that stumps enthusiasts
and skeptics alike
in this instance the footage in question
is from a north carolina high school
captured in the halls of ashfield high
school the short clip uploaded to
youtube by user jason highfield
displays a black wisp moving through the
air
hmm despite its short length the clip
has garnered a massive amount of
attention
if you slow the footage down and zoom in
there is indeed a black entity of some
kind
floating through the hall right
for one thing the security camera in
question is motion activated
meaning the wisp captured by the camera
seems to have had an
actual physical presence ah
okay that looks like a cool high school
that's the takeaway
for the mysterious activity is ghostly
they can offer no other explanation
similarly the asheville paranormal
society has nothing to offer by way of
debunking the footage
leaving asked to puzzle over the
two-second clip over and over again
it's hard to say i mean i feel like i
need more
[Laughter]
conclusion here i'm not sure i feel like
i need
more footage of weird things happening
at this high school to be like this high
school is haunted i feel like this thing
like it could
be like a moth or something like that
that's a freaking huge
moth we're talking about no but like if
it's like close to the screen or
something you know like
i don't think that's what's happening
right now like on the nest cameras you
know sometimes it'll give you like a
thing that something's happening but
it's just like like a spider or
something like sure
i don't know all i'm saying is i'm not a
hundred percent sold that this is
an actual ghost are you uh i think it
was a thing that occurred
i don't know if it was a ghost that
might have just been like it looks like
a glitch in the camera to me honestly i
know i don't think it was
like you know what i mean if it's flying
close to the lens it's obviously going
to look bigger
it would encompass the camera though oh
maybe it's a good point
you're such a good detective i know
right the only thing that lends credence
to the argument is the fact that it's a
motion detective camera so it's only
picking up motion yeah i mean i feel
like i would have been
way more freaked out if like that door
on the right opened and then we saw that
yeah should have added that a woman
walking in a bridge upside down position
just crawled across the floor that would
have really sucked up to me
this video has been floating around the
internet for quite a while now
and is credited to juelo el miedo
down the street as captured by a cctv
security camera
that is until the couple makes their way
about halfway down the road
suddenly what appears to be a small
white wisp appears
trailing just behind the couple what the
hell
that looks like a person
perhaps the most chilling part of the
entire experience
is that the couple seems to be
completely honest it looks like it's
doing the same motion
as the person in white in front of them
as they continue their way down the
street seemingly begins to become more
corporeal
nearly appearing to be the vague
suggestion of a child trailing just
behind the couple
oh that ghost just wants a friend what
do you think so far
it seems like the outline of like the
arm or something is like the same as the
person in white in front of them so i
don't know if the camera just did like
some weird double image
but i mean it's definitely something is
there just see i think
they're slowing it down right now i
think you're right it it mirrors way too
much
mirrors right see look the arm is like
up
kinda the body language just looks like
it's i think detective ashley just
solved the case is what i think
case closed there was no foul play here
[Laughter]
this video uploaded to facebook by user
alan valverde
shows an eerie entity caught on cctv
the video depicts an odd ghostly form
apparently moving around an empty place
what the hell
the large white figure moves back and
forth nearly constantly and
in circles looks like that ghost has had
some coffee it's just like
the motion detecting cameras focus on
the figure as it continues to move
around haphazardly that's weird
at one point two concerned security
guards are shown going out to the
parking lot in order to inspect the
space
it's clear from the footage that the men
don't actually see anything when they
make their way out to the parking lot
as at one point the figure even appears
to intersect with the men
[Music]
i thought there were people in as many
of the here commenters point out a
reflection of the figure is seen in the
puddles present on the ground oh true
ah compared with the camera's motion
detection it's clear that the white wisp
is not simply a trick of the light or
even a bug on the lens
whatever the entity is it seems to be
actually there
wreaking havoc in this inexplicable
footage
what do you think is this really a ghost
caught on cctv
i think that that one because of the
reflection on the water
that's pretty weird right no
it's totally normal i feel like
something could be there
yeah but isn't it like spazzing out
like the i know he's really fast like
sonic the hedgehog died
and just stuck in this little purgatory
of a circle right there
yeah i mean the fact that they were so
concerned as to even go out there
they were seeing something too yeah this
one i this
is up on the top rated of i believe that
yeah
i mean it's got to be something right
what kind of even glitch would that be
in your camera like i've never and
because there's the reflection on the
bottom and that's true and the fact that
these are
security guards or maybe they were like
maybe if we make a ghost video guys we
can get out of our shitty security job
no i'm sorry they're probably watching
this video
no they were on it they wanted to go
investigate don't you hate when you
watch a movie and like the security
guard is like oh that must be a glitch
in the camera
i'm not going to go check it out and
it's really a ghost yeah hey their
phone's on
they were on it they were securing the
area this video uploaded to youtube by
user rowit mukherjee
may actually depict a ghost caught on
camera
according to the title of the video this
sighting took place late one night in
tatanaga india
while walking home from work the man
behind the camera heard strange
shrieking noises coming from nearby
continuing to make his way down the path
the man began to notice there was
something not quite right about the
trees nearby
taking out his mobile phone and focusing
on the trees in order to get a better
look
the man was soon disturbed by what he
saw
the video shows a small shadowy figure
seemingly walking on air
floating between the trees or at the
very least
branch and the light post is like in the
shape of a cross
huh
[Laughter]
god run in another language
the outline of the human figure
suspended in the trees is clearly
visually distressing
but still brings us no closer to
answering what is
[Music]
see and i feel like he really did see it
because like you can hear the fear
that looked like a ghost i feel like
people in other countries they're more
in tune to it
yeah i feel like they're more accepting
of the possibilities yeah because
every time i watch these ghost videos
the creepiest ones are people who are
not speaking english
and are like referencing god you know
well i feel like i feel like they just
believe in it more you know
yeah that one categorized by america and
other countries yeah it's just
if you're not american you just believe
in it i just feel like they're just a
little bit more accepting that that
could be a possibility sure no but
that's definitely a figure and don't you
think that the thing
in a cross is also adding to the to the
scariness yeah would have been really
scary if the thing just burst in flames
or if it like did the slow turn over
like
i just want my cinematic tropes
in my real ghost videos that one gave me
that was good so that was a good one it
messes with the eye because you're like
what's he talking when you notice it
you're like oh wow that's terrifying
it looked like yeah like a girl with
long hair and a dry sock yeah
fake or not we're gonna go with real
just for credit for how good the video
is
while some videos of ghosts caught on
camera seem more sinister than others
this video uploaded to facebook by user
jenna howie
appears to have captured a trickster
spirit
what is meant to be a cute home video of
two small girls laughing and dancing
quickly turns into an inexplicably
disastrous play session
just a few short seconds into the video
a strange floating object appears in the
top left hand corner of the video
okay i'm nervous
the appearance of this object almost
immediately coincides
with the older of the two girls
seemingly being pushed or pulled back
violently to the ground what
as the girl's mother states in the
video's description the girl immediately
got back up from the fall with a smile
on her face
however this didn't stop her mother from
posting the video
in order to gauge popular opinion as to
what exactly happened in the seconds
leading up to her fall
that is weird that looks like something
pulled her look let's watch her feet the
actual intentions of the force that
worked against her remain unknown
wow there's nothing to clue the girl's
mother into knowing that the possible
ghost's intentions were playful
rather than harmful as the girl avoided
what could have been a serious injury
oh and she like went far back like i
feel like there was something
pulling her because like she loses her
footing like out of nowhere it wasn't
even like she was like twirling and
really
dancing you know that is scary
but the poor ghost just probably wanted
to play
or thought this is the chance to get
away with it oh yeah they're
fulfillment that one looked real i don't
know man like i
you think she just randomly got blown
back to the wall fly back she stumbled
i'm 30 years old and to this day i am
extremely clumsy
i'm 30 right now 31 i'm 30 years old and
i had that before i'm just like
you're just me are you really yeah you
chip
off ballots you have a slight panic
attack in your head for no warranted
reason and then you just
stumble back did you also have a dark
light above you when this happened
i don't know i'm usually not filming
myself
but i've had that happen where it's just
like i get i mean it's possible
i mean yeah with the light there and
then coming down and then it was like
perfect timing
yeah it was so all right fine we'll say
we'll say let's vote real okay i say
it's real
you don't agree i'm reluctantly agreeing
adding to the myriad of other concerns
parents must face in a day
it seems as though some paranormal
creatures just love
messing with children in this video
uploaded to youtube by user junet
channel a small boy is seen playing in a
pool with a man who appears to be his
father
it was a ghost family activity
something quite unusual happens at
around the seven second mark
as the boy's father lifts him up in the
pool both of his hands are accounted for
right however as he moves him through
the pool viewers will notice a
mysterious addition
whoa what is that clutching at the boy
how do we know it's not somebody who's
just right over no
whoa that is so weird oh my god
however after countless replays of the
video viewers are left scratching their
heads
wondering exactly where that additional
hand came from
why is it going for the kids to slow the
footage down and it becomes
frighteningly clear that an
unaccounted forehand does indeed reach
for the boy
and it just disappears under the pool it
goes under the floor his hand left as
quickly as it came the boy's parents
were probably more than a bit concerned
and bewildered
as with the video of the girl being
pushed or pulled forcefully back in her
home
this video will only serve to increase
the paranoia of parental figures
everywhere
which means better views for you i feel
like the only thing that i'm not sure
about that one is like the camera
doesn't pull
back too far right like it we don't
really see who else is in the pool that
water could be very
murky and there could be somebody
swimming underneath
i like how you're so like skeptical
about this one with the last one
the wider shot is pretty clear isn't it
i mean we don't
no we don't we don't know they're down
there i know we don't that's the whole
point we don't know it's down there
and that's what makes it terrifying i
just feel like there's water
look at that right there the hand
disappears it go this person is going
under and there's literally no one next
to them and then the parents they have
to be like underneath really like
yeah stretching yeah that's creepy it is
very creepy
because see who they pointing at now
i think you're reading it's in the most
unnecessary detail
what color were the nails i don't know
if it's like a ghost thing i don't know
i just feel like it's more of like an
optical illusion yeah but i don't know
you see a hand come up and frame reach
my kids ass
underwater yeah i'm a little skeptical
of this one for some reason
my guy is just telling me okay all right
you're the professional this video
uploaded to facebook by user jessica
soho
if true and unedited would have to be
one of the creepiest pieces of ghost
footage
ever captured the young filipino boy in
this clip
philippe is playing with his mother's
phone while she cooks dinner
one evening the mother let him be with
the phone and thought nothing of it
that is until much later when she
finally had the opportunity to review
the selfies her son had taken
and saved in her camera role what the
mother saw would shock her
as the videos showed her son and
deceased mother
side by side the video shows her son
with her mother's face barely in the
frame and mostly cut off with blackened
eyes
she hovers eerily to the left of screen
oh my god i i miss the idea
shows the grandmother when she was alive
clearly full of life
the still image on the left however has
sunken black eyes and grey skin
that is reviewing the photos later
terrified his mother ran to her eldest
son's bedroom to wake him up in the
middle of the night
and ask him if he knew anything about
the video his younger brother had taken
what did he say which the boy responded
that he had no idea what was going on
who's real so distressed the mother
decided that she must take steps to
contact a psychic
in an effort to discover if the spirit
was truly her mother
and why her mother had chosen to visit
her son now more than one year after her
passing
a follow-up video depicts the family and
the psychic attempting to make contact
with the grandmother
in order to discover her true purpose
lighting candles and communicating with
the deceased woman
the psychic would go on to explain to
the family that the grandma had simply
been lonely
the psychic advised the family that the
grandmother's spirit had actually been
distraught at the idea that they had
seemingly forgotten all about her
instructed to keep her in their prayers
in order to avoid making the
grandmother's
grandma unreal
grandmother's brave after the communion
wow what do you make of this eerie video
that is a terrifying video
boys deceased grandmother really
visiting that's like that isn't that
it's a ghost
yeah it's got to be that is terrifying
that one is really scary guys
subscribers slapped half you haven't
done so
already obviously well worth it but yeah
that last one
yeah oh me too i believe it
automatically pinoy pride baby you gotta
have their best
that's sad that the grandma thought she
was getting forgotten
grandma's like that you know how
grandmas are that was scary
my filipino grandma when she was alive
she thought that too you better think
about her a lot or she's gonna show up
on your phone
i could use some new socks now i'm
spooked
that was that was a good one that was
really good i mean i think three out of
five not bad or seven
four to seven yeah eight out of seven
yeah
they're all they're all really good
thank you ashley for being here oh yeah
i believe your detective skills really
do come in handy for such an occasion
oh thank you my work here is done
subscribe to
us if you want to hit the like button
evil season 2
june the 20th that's it ashley's going
on a
worldwide tour promoting
starting
great